into the night a fiery spout of lava and
clouds of dark smoke spew out of the
volcano in the commbre vieja national
park
the eruption began with a thunderous
roar earlier in the day and spain's
canary islands off the coast of
northwestern africa the island of la
palma had already been on high alert
after more than 22 000 tremors were
reported in the space of a week
but just days ago scientists had said
they didn't believe an eruption was
imminent
i don't know how to explain it it was
powerful powerful to see a sudden
explosion like that
we were on orange alert there were loads
of tremors but being on orange alert i
couldn't imagine it would all be so
sudden
the molten liquids shooting hundreds of
meters into the sky and pouring down the
hillside closer to some isolated
villages
thousands of people are being moved from
their homes but it's thought most of the
island's 85 000 residents are not at
risk
i'm very scared we didn't expect it we
were warned but we didn't expect it
we've had earthquakes all night this
morning i had to hold on to the tv
in the last major eruption there in 1971
one man was killed as he took
photographs near the lava flows
authorities are warning the curious not
to get too close and stay inside if
there's volcanic ash nearby
spanish prime minister pedro sanchez has
put off his trip to new york to attend
the un general assembly instead
traveling to the canary islands to meet
with local officials
right now we are keeping a close eye on
the fires that may happen as a result of
the eruption we will deploy not only the
civil guard who are already there but
also the national police forest
firefighters and members of the military
emergencies unit
the kumbra vieja is one of the most
active volcanic regions in the canaries
volcanologists say while it's too early
to know for sure this eruption could
last for weeks or even months alex
o'brien al jazeera